can you recall the meeting you had with
Ridley Scott like it was yesterday
and I will answer that but I'm gonna be
annoying and answer something I want to
talk about the mean I had before really
so because I think there's a teaching
moment in here so I had an idea for a
movie and I pitched it to my agent and
she goes out I think this is great let's
take it out to the marketplace and then
she said let's make a list of our dream
places that we want to sell it so she
goes if you could sell anyone who would
it be and it was so heavy I thought like
oh yeah who would I sell it to and I
said Ridley Scott you can't laugh like
okay yeah we'll take it there and then
when they come well we'll go down and
let them we'll go to places that
actually could so I go into really Scott
and I pitched with sue Williams who is a
development executive smart nicest woman
and you know this is really important
when you're pitching is you're trying to
get as much information so I was
pitching her this project and at some
point I saw her body language shift and
I go it was it's something off about
that and she goes really doesn't like
these kind of things I don't think I
think this is really exciting for him
but not if it's going down that road and
like what kind of things is really like
and so she started sharing things was so
helpful so we could kind of retool the
pitch together and so she was
instrumental so when you go someone
you're pitching you know you're trying
to get as much information from that
person and it's a real sometimes writers
have ego and they're like yeah I'm going
in this place and I'm pitching the
little lowest person on the totem pole
oh that's great because you get
information about the decision-maker
okay so sue Williams help me reformulate
the pitch in a way that would be a
better fit for Ridley so that was
amazing and that was I will forever be
grateful for her then I got brought in
to pitch to Mimi who was at the time
relays producing partner and this is a
long pitch this is a almost an hour
pitch it's like a 50-minute pitch this
is not a short pitch I always hate when
people say your pictures have to be this
amount of time there's no rules like
first of all when someone says you have
you have to do your pitch in ten minutes
people think that people will listen to
you for ten minutes they'll listen to
you as long as they're interested and if
they're not interested 30 second
they tune you out and most pitches that
sell are longer pitches because people
want to have the confidence that this
has been worked out and what they're
buying is legit anyway it says the long
pitch so I'm pitching the me me and it
can't be going worse she's sitting back
like this she's not making an eye
contact she looks in pain she looks like
this pitch is so bad that it is making
her go crazy and the only reason I have
a career is at the time I wanted to be
doing stand-up or improv so I was
pursuing that and an improv I was
learning that one of my problems my
weaknesses is when I thought things were
going well I was alive and animated but
when I thought things weren't going
about any thought it was into it my fear
of rejection run this through this I
would sort of back off and sort of tune
out of the scene I kind of let you guys
take it I would just sort of drop out of
the scene which is you don't do that as
an improviser so what I was being taught
is when you think things are going
terrible walk to the center of the stage
take focus and say something and just
stay in there stay alive don't worry
about people's judgments follow your
process so I'm pitching in after about
seven minutes I'm like she hates me she
hates this pitch she's never gonna buy
it she's in pain and that voice says
just do the short version and get out of
here this is painful for her it's
painful for you Gridley was never gonna
buy this pitch just get out of here just
wrap it up and go which I would do as a
stand-up terrible habit but another
voice said okay look you're never gonna
be a writer as evidenced by the pain
you're causing this woman maybe you
could be a performer so use this as a
way of practicing your improv skills
stay engaged stay engaged that that
voice went through my head so I stay
engaged and I I just did the pitch with
gusto and focus and try not to look too
much that me didn't see how much pain
she was in and I finished and then there
was just silence I mean looking for
silence and then she stands up and she
goes hmm I don't get it and then sue
Williams said well what don't you get
she goes all of it and she looked at me
and she was like something like maybe
we'll be in touch or just something and
walked out
and sue didn't know what to say I didn't
have to say and then I left and I drove
home and I called my agent and I'm like
well you were right Ridley's not gonna
buy this then sue calls me and I pick up
the phone you know and she's like hey
when you pitched with me you were really
good but when you pitched for me me and
I know where this was going she said you
were on fire I mean even loved it
now there's a lesson in this which is
don't try to read the room because I've
pitched two people I pitched the heads
of Studios that laughed and loved it
because they when someone's hearing a
pitch they're trying to decide am I
gonna buy this am I gonna take this to
my boss that's could be stressful and I
pitched to a studio once where he knew
right away he wasn't gonna buy it
because they had a similar idea and
development so he just relaxed and had
fun with me we had a great time but he
already knew he wasn't gonna buy it
I found out Mimi like only takes one or
two pitches to Ridley a year and when
she was hearing this pitch she was like
internally going oh my god
this is something really would really
love and I can't speak for her but I'm
guessing that maybe she was nervous
because maybe she was thinking do I
really want to put my career on the line
with this guy like I was a nobody I was
in film school I hadn't I was was like
23 and green as they came and I think
that she probably hearing the pitch was
having an internal debate you know again
I can't speak for her but that's my
guess so Seuss she was like yeah I
probably should have told you she could
be a little like that's sort of her way
she listens so don't read people's like
I've been in rooms where people seem
like they hated it and sometimes they do
and sometimes they don't stay committed
have integrity do the pitch okay so to
your question sorry for the long window
so I was told that really wouldn't be
back in town for a month Mimi did have
one big concern that she wanted changed
it was a hard creative thing to figure
out but I'm like I have a month to
figure it out
few days later I told you I got a phone
call here's what I didn't tell you I
don't drink much alcohol I'm just a
lightweight I'm the cheapest date ever
and the night before I was at some party
and I drank
more than I'd ever drink in my life and
it doesn't take much to get me drunk I
think that morning might have been my
first ever hangover or was the worst
ever hangover so when the phone rang I
hadn't showered it was hadn't shaven I
was hungover it was my agent and she
said Ridley's in town and he would like
to hear the pitch he has an hour he has
a slot in an hour can hear the pitch and
it takes 45 minutes to get there to
Beverly Hills from where I was and so I
said and it's not a good idea but I said
oh that's exciting
can we bump it up till 2:00 and there
was this long pause and I know my agent
was thinking why did I sign this guy and
she said so Cory
Ridley's in town he has a slot he'd like
to hear your pitch in an hour
and at least then I was like of course I
will be there in an hour
this kind of works out to my favor so I
quickly shave and shower and on the
dried drink coffee on the drive over I'm
just figuring out how to solve that
creative problem what happened is I got
there with a second to spare and they
dripped me into the room with him I
never had the chance to get nervous I
never had a chance to psych myself out I
was just on pure adrenaline and Ridley
was the sweetest person ever he came in
the room you know and I started to like
you know it's an honor and it was like
Blade Runner and alien like I it was a
literal honor to be in a room with him
let alone the fact that he was gonna
listen to me he pitched a project and he
just immediately said like I you know
were just two creative people I want to
hear your idea you don't have to be
great at performing might my staff loves
it I just want to hear like he went out
of his way to make me feel comfortable
and that I belong there
because I did not feel like I belong to
in a room pitching to really Scott and I
was just on adrenaline with no prep you
know psyched myself out and so I just
started talking and he was just he
listened and he and he nodded and he was
so receptive and he was so loving and
gentle
I'll I'll never forget that and he was
just amazing and then at the end he
asked the question he always want to
hear which is he said so who else has
heard this pitch and I said nobody
you're the first pitch your first play
well who else is going to hear this
pitch and I gave some of the places that
we had meetings set up and he looked at
his staff and then he turned to me and
he said who's your agent and I told him
Dan Karen's ICM and he called my agent
and he said I want to take this off the
market so that was just like I I really
thought I was dreaming and then I
remember I was driving home in my like
cruddy little car and I will slim Doug's
car because he had to use your feet to
stop it thumbskull no money car and I
was driving on the 405 and I started
shaking I just was shaking I had a
pullover and the thought that went
through my head wasn't that I just
launched my career it wasn't that I just
saw the thought that went through my
head was I just met Ridley Scott I'm so
nerdy I was just and not only that once
the deal was consummated they said we
want you on the next plane to London so
that Ridley and his team will develop
the structure with you and they meant
the literal next plane to London so my
wife and I my girlfriend at the time now
wife Rebecca we were like she's like
I'll help you pack because I don't know
how to pack and I'm like great and she's
getting all my clothes just where's your
suitcase I'm like what I don't have oh
you know I don't so we ran to like
Target and bought a suitcase and
everything and then they flew me
first-class and I didn't know
first-class exist I didn't know what
first-class was I didn't grow up with no
money so they kept bringing me like food
and wine and I was like no no no I I was
thinking I can't afford this you know
like I can't afford I don't want to pay
for all this when I land and then in
some point in London someone said no in
first-class it's all included so no way
back I was like more food but yes
relieved just I mean he treated me
throughout the entire process and he
called me when they weren't gonna make
it and he explained
which he didn't have to do throughout
the entire process he treated me like a
like a writer who belonged to be there
and someone that he wanted he wanted to
hear my opinions he didn't want me just
to defer to him I mean it was amazing
forever be grateful for that he spoiled
me because at some point I was like well
I thought everyone now that's how the
way I'd worked for some of the best
people in the business I thought they
treat writers and I've worked with
people who don't treat writers that way
so when you pulled over on the 405 do
you remember was there a song playing on
the radio or I don't I just write think
I remember I was gonna crash that's a
good gosh I don't remember I just kept
thinking I saw I came home and my
girlfriend was like so and I'm like I
met Ridley Scott and she's like I know
you meant Ridley Scott but oh yeah he
bought he bought it I was just I was
just a little film scold nerd who was
excited to me Ridley Scott
you